hey everybody sean here with a gamespot
news update februari was a great month
for games hardware and software with
strong sales for almost everybody
regardless of platform Sony's
PlayStation 4 led hardware sales by a
narrow ten percent margin over the Xbox
one however the higher price point of
Microsoft's console gave the Xbox one an
edge on a per dollar basis microsoft
also announced in a separate release
that the Xbox platform combining xbox
one and 360 sold more hardware than any
other home console platform which would
put it above the ps3 Vita and ps4 as
well as the Wii U and 3ds combinations
regardless of spin it's good news for
both companies and the NPD reported that
most hardware platforms experienced
double to triple digit increases
compared to january 2014 software sales
were also very positive game sales for
both the Xbox one and the ps4 were up
eighty percent compared to the combined
first four months sales for the xbox 360
and ps3 and Nintendo's 3ds RPG bravely
default even made it into the top ten
total game sales so that's good news for
all console enthusiasts will be covering
every single one of these platforms here
on gamespot com